chief tom manger that said that there
was no evidence that loudermilk was
giving a tour of the capitol building
itself but it didn't necessarily absolve
him of any wrongdoing
oh my god this is odious here now is the
aforementioned congressman barry
laudermill congressman
first of all your reaction to the
developments tonight and you're cleared
but cnn says oh not so fast
well laura thanks for having me on and
thanks for actually covering this you
know just
three or four weeks ago i find out about
these accusations not from a letter that
the committee sent to me no they sent it
to the press as i'm going to the airport
and then i'm seeing my picture on the
television screens of all these
passengers that are seeing that i'm some
kind of strange conspiracy uh or evil
conspirator here and it's just
ridiculous that the way that they're
handling this committee and they keep
moving the goal post you know the
original charge was we gave tours of the
capitol there were no tours of the
capitol that day video evidences there
were no tours of the capitol then they
say oh it was at the capitol complex
there were hundreds of people in the
capital complex the house office
buildings in fact it was the democrat
leadership ordered the gift shop open on
the 5th because there were so many
visitors there so mickey cheryl's
accusation that there were no tours
allowed well there were no tours allowed
at the capitol but there were plenty of
people at the house office buildings
because it was just another day and now
when it comes out and
no mistake about it the capitol police
were clear that they are trained in
looking for suspicious activity and the
group i had in the house office
buildings had
did nothing suspicious
congressman
it was a lie
it was a smear
they did the same thing to donald trump
for years and then when it's shown to be
nothing they said well it's not really
exonerate it's not really exact we're
still looking into it which is what the
january 6 committee said to cnn said oh
no we have other information i guess
about
you or this that's going to come to
light did you did you catch that on the
cnn report we cut it off before they
actually said that but that's actually
what they referenced
well i'm sure the committee's going to
move the goal post to try to save face
look there was nothing nefarious that
happened on the fifth to most of us and
i guess to all of us we had no idea what
was going to transpire on the six it was
just another legislative day but the
biggest problem i have is the way that
the committee has conducted itself they
never contacted me at all if they wanted
to know the truth all they had to do was
pick up the phone and call me many of
the members have my cell phone number
they all has a have a house uh phone
directory they could have called me and
asked questions about this group of
constituents but they make an accusation
yeah that's a sign i get death threats
i mean
i'm getting death threats my family's
getting death threats my staff getting
death threats and you know today is the
fifth anniversary of when a deranged man
that was
radicalized by extreme
political rhetoric walked on the
baseball field and tried to kill me and
many of my colleagues
people do stupid things based off of
what they hear out of the media
and i hold i hold the committee
responsible if somebody gets hurt
through all well and congressman a
journalist who irresponsibly reported
this and and should have known better if
you can if you can find malice uh you
might have some legal action there so i
hope you're pursuing that congressman
thank you very much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else